okay i'm going to do a new
video in english just uh
waiting for the opponent to arrive
rather long wait unusually
for the five minute pull in icc
game started oh this is strange
just give me a second to adjust the
recording area
okay this should be fine i lost 20
seconds though
well first game it's not especially
easy to play it's a grand master
um bashan
this is um
grand master garage beta from hungary
they go play um achievable
lopez
yeah this is a very old line sometimes
called the rubinstein system
some very solid for black
also a little bit passive but
my results are not that bad with the
setup
but it's always difficult against the
strong grandmaster of course
yeah black tries to the ranges
pieces on the king side to
basically soak up the pressure there
it hopes that you can hold the queen
side
white is a little bit quicker on the a
file
we have to break down this position
yeah he's got the a file now queen a3
most probably
still it's not not easy to to get
anything
concrete here
it's a bit problematic to to make
progress with white i hope this is at
least my experience in the previous
games
yeah maybe he tries to rearrange the
knight to a3 or
also play f4 this could also be an
um an idea for white
what i like to do is but usually it's
not
not possible to exchange the c7
bishop on b6
well it's a try anyway
now queen b8 was my idea
maybe is it an idea for him to play
queen a6
then maybe queen a6
bishop c8 and queen c6
maybe it is an idea to to get another
piece over to the queen side
uh-huh that's interesting
maybe he tries to
switch back to g1 to prevent this
exchange
could be
hmm queen bishop b6 now what
what is he doing after that
see if anything dangerous
i don't see it at the moment so
i go for that
i just want to go to the end game yeah
okay
check this is sometimes a problem
for black because white may have
a piece sacrifice on c4 to get to
passports or
simply attack with knight to a3
i still have rook b8 to cover
one problem for white is the knight on
e2 which is very really a bad piece
it can't do anything active at the
moment next step in defense
is knight c7 and rook a8 to get
rid of the rook and then i just need to
position
properly to take care about the possible
p sacrifices yeah
okay of course i could take here but
this would also give up d4 i'd just like
to
like to keep the position closed here
and another circumstance would be an
idea to take of course because i also
get e5 but
this would activate the the knight
okay it's interesting
i still could take with the knight but i
don't want to give even this
this square so i take with the pawn
now rook a8 and i exchanged the rook
here
okay check
okay this knight is on b6 to
cover c4 as well
next step would be to to bring my knight
to f6
is there a good root not
h6 perhaps
yeah of course he would like to exchange
exchange but i just i just
go to f6
i have c4 also double covered so
you won't be easily able to
to sacrifice
still it's not possible to to do
anything active with black
you just have to stay draw offered
either of a draw game yeah
yeah it's um it's simply that
white cannot do anything and
well maybe i could have tried a little
bit here but it's
um it's still not not easy to see
how you will make progress only idea
would be
maybe h6 and g5 or gen in general go for
g5
the only pawn break left in the position
but still it's hard to see that this
should lead to anything
really great most likely is just to draw
because of the blocked nature
nature of the position but considering
my
bad form earlier today i'm pretty glad
to have started with the draw against
the grandmaster so
that's okay